I just pasted in this message and I'm
shooting it off to Claude and it says,
create a team called Neuroflow of three
teammates using Sonnet. The first one is
a front-end developer, the second one is
a back-end developer, and the third one
is a QA agent. So, this now invoked a
tool called team create. And you can see
that what it's doing is now that it's
created this team, it's spawning up
three teammates in parallel. And these
are all individual agents. So, right now
we can see we have our front-end
developer, we have our back-end
developer, and we have our QA agent. So,
what's happening is right now we have
these three agents working together with
our main session. They all share a task
list, they can talk to each other, and
I'm going to check back in with you guys
once this is done. Okay, so this is
really interesting. The front-end and
back-end developer sent work over to the
QA agent, and then the QA agent found
three critical issues. So, the main
agent said that it's going to send all
of this work right back to those first
two agents to take another pass at it.
So, here's where you can see it sent off
those messages to the front-end
developer, the back-end dev, and the QA.
And now they're all back to work once
again. And there we go, the second time
the QA agent gives it a pass. All three
of those critical issues have been
resolved. And then it was able to
basically one-shot this website. Now,
obviously there are some things that
aren't perfect about this and we'd want
to go back and iterate, but considering
in the prompt all I said was to build me
a landing page for a fictional AI
startup and we get all of this text, we
get these animations, we get all of this
stuff to come in dynamically, and it
feels pretty polished. It came up with
all the copy, the color scheme, all of
it. This is truly one of the most
powerful AI agent features I've ever
used, but you have to know how to use it
right, which is why in today's video I'm
going to explain everything you need to
know, what they are, how to set them up,
how to use them, when not to use them,
everything that you need. So, let's not
waste any time and get straight into the
video. So, agent teams. As you guys saw
in the demo, we had one get spun up
called Neuroflow, and in that team we
had three agents. We had the front-end
dev, the back-end dev, and the QA. So,
what happens is the main orchestrator,
the Claude code session you're talking
to, creates these different agents and
manages them. But not in the same way
that we do sub agents, because sub
agents work independently and then they
send their individual result back to the
main agent. Agent teams have a team
lead, maybe like a project manager, and
it creates all of these different agents
and a shared task list. So, the huge
unlock here is that individual teammates
can talk to each other. So, sometimes
there's a dependency. Teammate one needs
something from teammate two, and they
can just talk. And you can get in these
really cool loops, especially when you
have the QA agent like we just saw in
the demo, where one of the teammates
will basically say, "Hey, this isn't
good enough." and send the work back.
And then the main agent, like I said, is
just making sure that the tasks are
getting done and that they're all high
quality. So, that's the big difference
between sub-agents and agent teams, and
I had to clear that up because I know
that's probably where there's some
confusion. So, I am going to break more
stuff down, but what I want to do first
is just show you guys how to set this up
because I think the best way to learn is
just to be able to play around with
stuff. And all you have to do to set
this up is add one environment variable
into your project setting. So, let me
show you how that works right now. All
right, here I am in Cloud Code. I like
to use it in VS Code, but you can use
the agent teams feature wherever you
decide to use Cloud Code. You can see
that I am in a brand new project with
nothing in it. So, this is exactly what
one of you guys' setup should look like
if you want to follow along. So, like I
said, we need to enable the feature, and
I'm going to do that in this demo on the
project level. So, what I'm going to do
is go to the official Cloud Code
documentation for agent teams, and you
can see right here that it says they are
disabled by default because it's an
experimental feature. So, you have to
enable them by adding this variable into
your settings.json. So, what I'm going
to do is literally just copy this JSON
right here and come into Cloud Code and
say, "Hey, I need you to put this in our
local settings in this project." and
then just paste in that JSON prompt. And
I'm going to go ahead and shoot that
off, and that should basically be able
to create that file for us. So, you can
see that it set everything up. We now
have a .cloud folder. If I click in
here, we have a settings.local.json,
and it has put that command in there.
And now our project should be set up to
actually be able to use agent teams.
Now, before we dive in and I start
showing you guys how to do that, there
is one thing that I recommend doing
first. And that's basically training
your Cloud Code project on how agent
teams work so that they can actually be
used as effectively as possible. So, the
easiest way to do this is you go to the
documentation on agent teams, you take
the URL, and you copy it. And then I
said, "Hey, create me a master reference
guide for agent teams in a folder called
docs. This will be used to help you
build better and more effective agents
in the future." And now it's going to
read through that documentation. And now
if you ever have questions about agent
teams or if it ever needs to look up
something while it is building them, it
already has that locally here stored as
markdown. So it's going to be much
quicker. And it just created this
documentation about enabling them, when
to use them, display modes, task
management, hooks, best practices, tons
of stuff like that. And that can be
found in the docs folder in this
section, which is a full markdown file
with
hundreds of lines. And that's just a
little tip. That's something that I like
to do whenever I have like maybe a big
MCP server or certain documentation that
I know it might need to look at
constantly. So now that we're pretty
much set up and ready to start building,
let's talk about prompting. How do we
actually tell Claude code to build us
agent teams, but not just to build them,
but to actually make them really good to
give you what you want. Because the
truth about agent teams is that they are
more expensive and they are a bit
slower, but you do get much higher
quality if you use them right. Now the
good news is you can pretty much invoke
them just using natural language. So I
kind of follow this pattern. Create a
team of X number of agents using X
model. So Haiku, Sonnet or Opus.
And then you basically just say the
agents that you want. You would say
the first agent is X role.
This agent should be doing this and it
should produce me this.
It can talk to the other agents to do X,
Y and Z.
And so pretty much just listing that out
in natural language. Whether that be an
API designer, a database engineer and or
a test writer. So let's take a real
quick look at an example prompt. So I'm
going to read this full one out. Now
what you'll notice is I start off by
establishing a goal. The reason I do
this is because when the agents wake up,
they have no context. They basically
only get the prompt that the main
session feeds into them. So if we tell
the main agent a goal to give to the sub
agents, they understand a little bit
better, you know, like what they're
working towards, but also why they have
their teammates next to them. So the
goal here is to build a working full
stack app with a rest API and a react
front end. The end result should be a
running app that I can view on a local
host. It should have users and post
functionality plus a QA test report
confirming that everything works. So
then I said, "Hey, create me a team of
three teammates using Sonnet. The first
one's a back-end dev, it should be doing
this. The second one is a front-end dev,
and it should be doing this. And the
third one is a QA agent that should be
doing this." You can see that in the
descriptions I said, "When you're done,
message the front-end dev." And then in
this one I said, "Wait for the back-end
dev's message, and then you will send
all this stuff to the QA." And then I'm
saying what the final deliverables
should be because the main agent spins
these three up, and then it's going to
get a bunch of information back. So what
do I actually want at the end of the
day? I want a running app, I want a
report about pass and fail tests, and
then I want a doc, which is basically
what was built, key decisions, and how
we run this moving forward. So we're
about to hop right back into Claude Code
and live prompt an agent. But real
quick, let's talk about some dos and
don'ts. So do have each agent own
specific files because if you don't do
this and agents are sharing files, they
might overwrite each other's work, which
is not good. Do define the output, don't
use vague deliverables. Do name
recipients, don't just assume that
they're going to understand who to talk
to and why. Do have about three to five
teammates, don't go for massive agent
swarms of 10+. That'll also be 10 times
more expensive. And do give full context
because of the fact that no history is
given beforehand. Now of course, they
can still read everything in the
project, they can still look through all
of those files, but no context is fed in
initially. And I will show you exactly
what I mean by that when we go in here
and spin up a new agent team. Okay, so
I'm in that project that we set up
together. I'm in a fresh session, and
I'm going to send off this prompt. I
said that the goal is to help me clean
up the workspace. We have three agents
called research team. We're using
Sonnet. We've got a researcher, a
strategist, and a critic, and they're
basically just going to read through
this project and make sure that
everything's accurate and make sure that
we're set up good. Let's take a look at
what's going on. It's creating the
research team, right? So it's created
the team, and now we have a to-do list.
Now what it's doing is it's going to
spawn the three teammates in parallel.
And when it spawns these, I'm going to
actually show you how. So the first one
is a researcher. If I click into this,
you can see that this says in. So this
is basically saying this is what the
main agent sent to the agent. You are
the researcher on the research team,
here is what your job is, and you have
to be thorough and include anything that
might be helpful. So this is basically
the prompt that spun up that agent. You
can see same exact thing happened for
the strategist and for the critic. And
if I clicked in, we could once again
read exactly what they were prompted to
do and the step-by-step instructions.
Including stuff like when you're done,
send your five use cases to the critic
teammate using the send message tool.
Which once again validates that these
agents are able to talk to each other
and send messages to each other. So now
we can see that all three of our agents
are running and they are all basically
just waiting for their turn. And you'll
notice what it does is pretty much every
time there's a new update, it updates
me. So here comes another live update.
Let's see if the researcher is finally
done. There we go, it's done. So now
what happens is we sent a message off to
the researcher. And let's go ahead and
see what that message actually said. So
this is the main agent talking to the
researcher. It said, "Did you send your
structured inventory to both the
strategist and the critic? Please make
sure the strategist also received it.
You were asked to message both
teammates." And then we can see that the
researcher confirmed that both teammates
received the inventory and now the
critic is running. All right, so
everything just finished up. All the
reports are here. But real quick, I
wanted to draw your attention to this.
The main agent said, "Cool, let me shut
down the teammates and finalize."
I'll touch on this a little bit later,
but now the main agent has sent a
message to each of them, the researcher,
the strategist and the critic, and
basically said, "You're done.
Save your work." So anyways, we'll come
back to that in a little bit, but we now
have an output, which is a new document
over here, Agent Teams Patterns, and it
found a ton of stuff. There were 11
documentation gaps identified that are
worth reviewing against your reference
doc. So anyways, let's just click into
the doc real quick. We're not going to
read this whole thing cuz I'm assuming
it is super long, but this is the actual
output that we just got from this agent
team, and you can see that this thing is
insanely thorough. So, if you wanted to
really, really understand how agent
teams work, then spin up an agent team
to help you explain agent teams. Now,
what you'll notice here is we were kind
of able to see what was going on, but
not really under the hood. We couldn't
actually tell what the agents were
thinking or doing, and that's because
we're doing this in the Cloud Code
extension. If you do this in your
terminal, and specifically if you have
tmux installed, you can actually see the
different agents working and thinking,
and you can individually send messages
to them. Because right here we're kind
of only communicating through the main
session, and the main session sends
messages to the other ones. But one of
the value props of agent teams is that I
could individually message a sub-agent
if I wanted to. So, let me show you what
that looks like.
All right, so right now I'm running
Cloud Code in a tmux terminal. Now, if
you're on Windows, you have to take a
little bit of a work around, but you
just have to be in a tmux terminal. So,
I'm not going to do a full setup video
on it right now, but I literally just
had Cloud Code walk me through it, and
it was super simple. But anyways, what I
did here is I just pasted in this
prompt, which obviously is like we
talked about, we have the goal, we say
create me an agent team, and then we
have our front-end dev, our back-end
dev, and our QA. This is basically the
same exact prompt that I ran in the
demo, so this isn't to show you the
actual deliverable. What I want to show
you guys here is the way that we can
visually see this. So, right here what
it's going to do is it's going to spin
up that agent team for us, right? It's
setting up the task dependencies, and
it's assigning owners, and now it's
spawning those agents. And there we go,
we just got our front-end dev created
right here, and this is the blue agent.
We have another one right here, which is
the back-end dev, and this is the green
agent. And there we go, we just got our
QA agent, which is the yellow one. So,
now I very clearly can see what each of
these agents is doing, which is super
cool. And now if I wanted to, I could
come over here, and I could check on the
team status with the main session. I
could come up here, and I could talk to
the front-end dev, I could approve
things, or I could give it more info.
Same exact thing with the QA, or same
exact thing with the back-end dev. So,
now I literally have an agent team that
I can watch, and I can interact with any
of them. And I can also watch them do
research, create things, talk to each
other. It's super, super cool. So, like
I said, I'm not going to run this whole
thing out. I just wanted to show you
guys that this is possible. Okay, now
that we've seen some cool demos, let's
talk about how do we actually make these
things better and better and understand
a little bit more about what's going on.
So, here are three key rules. The first
one is that each of these agents has
their own territory. So, they should
have their own file and they should be
working on their own deliverables. They
can send them across and they can
communicate, but they should only really
all be editing their own thing. The
second thing is, once again, direct
messaging. They can talk to each other.
They don't have to use the middleman of
the main session. And then the third
piece is that they can be working at the
same time. It doesn't have to be agent
one hands off to agent two and then
agent two hands off to agent three,
because that honestly might not even
call for an agent team. Agent teams work
together in parallel and need to
communicate throughout the whole
process. So, what do teammates instantly
know when they wake up? Because we know
that they don't have any context from
the jump. What they do have is they
inherit the permissions from the main
session. So, if you're on bypass
permissions, then all of your agents are
going to be on bypass permissions. If
you allow all bash commands, then those
same permissions will once again be
inherited by the teammates. But the
other thing to know that's very
important is that any of your files, any
of your MCP servers, any of your skills,
all of the teammates can use and access
those things. We also have a really cool
ability to use something called plan
approval mode. So, you guys know how
I've told you always start in plan mode.
If you plan with your main session
before anything actually happens, it's
way better. What we can do is we can
have all of those agent teammates plan
first and they have to basically get
their plan approved by the main agent
before they're actually allowed to go
execute. So, it's really cool. You could
also set it up where you're actually the
one who has to approve every single
plan, but I think it's probably better
to just have the main session do that.
Or maybe even one of the teammates is
just the plan reviewer and approver. So,
I wanted to talk about some common
pitfalls or mistakes that you might be
making and what the fix could be for
that.
So, the first one is if the agents keep
asking permissions and they keep
stopping for that. You can pre-approve
certain tools. So, that would be in your
project settings or your local settings.
You can allow certain commands, and that
way they won't stop to ask you something
every couple seconds. If the
deliverables aren't coming out feeling
holistic, maybe they're being
overridden, so make sure that you assign
file owners. If you spin up an agent
team and you realize that one of the
agents isn't really doing much or is
just sitting around, then maybe you want
to specifically make sure you're
assigning each agent work or some sort
of dependency in your plan in your
prompt. If you're burning through way
too many tokens, just use fewer agents.
If it seems like your agents are losing
work, then tell them to basically store
everything as a temporary file that they
can then call on later. And if you're
getting the wrong approval and it just
seems like it's off, then maybe just try
to have you be the one who approves
things to start until you understand the
flow of how these teams work a little
better. All right, so next I wanted to
talk about when to use agent teams
because like I said earlier, they can be
slow and expensive, so you really just
want to use them when you need something
pretty complex done, and you need lots
of different specialized agents. So,
think about using them if your specific
process or project has multiple areas,
and that way you can have one
specialized in each of those. If you
need those things to be done in
parallel. If you need them to be able to
react to each other, assign tasks to
each other, communicate with each other.
And if something needs to be done at a
really high quality and you want tons of
different steps to make sure, then an
agent team is probably a decent idea.
Now, if you have a process that could be
done sequentially, meaning every time it
basically goes one, two, three, and
those steps are dependent on each other,
then maybe an agent team isn't the right
call. Maybe that's just sub agents. If
you need everything in one specific
conversation history or one context
window, then don't use teams. If you're
just kind of working on the same files,
don't use teams. And if it's a very
simple task, then agent teams would be
overkill. There might be a lot of times
where you'd be able to use sub agents
instead. Like I said, with sequential or
if you need a very focused result. If
you don't need the agents to
communicate, and if you want to save
some tokens. Because once again, if you
have three sessions running, that's
basically going to be three times the
cost. So, if you have five, it'll be
five times the cost. Which means I like
to stay around maybe two to five agents
max. You can keep them running parallel.
Otherwise, you can use sub agents and
make sure that you are shutting them
down if you see them early on going off
down the wrong path. Which is another
reason why I think it's helpful to use
the tmux version, so you can actually
see them in that split pane view. And
when I say shut down, which is kind of
what we saw earlier, I just mean
basically at the end of every session
saving your work. Because remember right
here how we saw the main session say,
"Hey, this is a shut down request." The
researcher agent here could have said,
"I'm not done yet. Let me save stuff.
Don't shut me down yet." So when the
teammates actually confirm that they're
ready to be shut down, that means that
everything's good and we can essentially
cleanly save that work. So everything
gets cleaned up and then we're good to
close the session and shut down that
agent team rather than just force
killing it right away where things might
be all out of control and not cleaned up
yet. Well, all right. That is agent
teams. I hope by now you are excited to
hop into Cloud Code and start building
with some agent teams. And if you want
to check out other Cloud Code stuff that
I've been doing to expand your learning,
then definitely check out this video
right up here. Hopefully I'll see you
guys over there, but that is going to be
the end of the video. So if you enjoyed
it and you learned something new, please
give it a like. It definitely helps me
out a ton. And as always, I appreciate
you guys making it to the end of the
video. I'll see you on the next one.
Thanks, everyone.